four years ago i predicted that donald
trump could win
nobody wanted to listen to me too many
politicians from
from both sides of the aisle benefit
from loopholes
that they don't want to see close and
your party is just as bad as the
republicans in that isn't it
barring unforeseen events joe biden will
take the white house next month
but with his party deeply divided are
the democrats really celebrating
my guest this week from washington is
democratic congresswoman
debbie dingle is biden a man with a
vision
or will he struggle simply to control
his party
and the urgent crises donald trump will
leave behind
[Music]
debbie dingle welcome to conflict zone
you're an unusual party
joe biden wins the most powerful job in
the world and you
all kick off a blame game about why you
didn't do better what's the matter with
you
well i'm one of those people that says
we need to stop pointing fingers
and we need to take a deep breath and
try to understand why
so many people voted for donald trump as
well
i think that people are disappointed
that we have the closest majority we've
had in the house in decades
and that's going to make it a challenge
at times we don't know where the senate
is going to
end up but quite frankly i'm of a mood
it's going to force us to work together
you don't want to point fingers but a
lot of your colleagues seem to don't
they
one of the first shots in this war was
fired by your colleague in the house of
representatives abigail spamberg
she was one of the moderates heaping
blame on the left wing of the party for
losing
seats in the house of representatives we
need she said to not ever use the word
socialist or socialism again we lost
members we shouldn't have lost
if we're classifying tuesday that's
election day as a success
we'll get torn apart in 2022. that
really kicked it off didn't it
well it did in some ways but you know i
would encourage
i'm one of the co-chairs of our policy
and messaging committee
for the house of representatives and i
think we really have to take time to
understand everybody's perspectives very
early on
four years ago i predicted that donald
trump could win
nobody wanted to listen to me
but i believed that democrats were doing
a very
bad job of talking about trade and that
donald trump recognized the fear that
workers had
in their heart about how our trade
policies had shipped jobs
overseas and that is one of the reasons
i believe donald trump won in 216.
early on in this campaign probably by
april or may of this year
i said to the biden campaign we have to
deal
with uh this defund the police issue
it matters in communities police are the
backbone
of many of our communities and suburbs
we do have a real problem in this
country
that if you're a young black man you are
being treated differently by law
enforcement
but not all law enforcement is bad and
that we needed to be prepared to have
uncomfortable conversations but to deal
with this
and i do believe it was an issue in many
districts across the country
um the messaging was an issue wasn't it
because it didn't fit all areas it
wasn't a one size fit all
one one house member mickey cheryl
seemed to be speaking for many others
when she said she'd
managed to overcome the national
messaging that had been so detrimental
to so many candidates
it's pretty bad isn't it when candidates
find their own party's messaging is
something
that they have to overcome and you you
paid for that in rural areas and also
among blue collar workers didn't you
well you know this is what i'm going to
say i have a very diverse
district i actually have one of the most
diverse districts in the country
i'm very proud of the fact that i
represent uh
uaw workers steel workers teamsters are
a significant part
of what we call the down rivers in my
district but i also represent one of the
most liberal parts of this country
uh in ann arbor michigan where the home
of the university of michigan
is and many progressives i say the same
thing
no matter where i am and what i try to
do is to get
both sides to listen to each other i
think each
it's incumbent upon each member you are
running to represent
your district to talk to your district
to talk about the issues that matter
and to just be very straightforward i'm
not
i i think too many politicians talk
gobbledygook
uh i think that's one of the reasons
donald trump won four years ago too
because he because he [ __ ] or didn't
he talked in simple terms that people
could understand and and
you didn't it seems clear debbie dingle
that one thing joe biden will not be
is a powerful president not only does he
have to worry about keeping
the various wings of his party together
but if he fails to pick up
two senate seats in georgia that have a
runoff next month
most of the big ticket items that he
wants to pass will die in the senate or
won't even make it onto capitol hill
will they
that's a narrow space to maneuver in i'm
going to very much disagree with you
i think joe biden is the president of
the times and i think he could be
a very powerful president he is someone
that has the ability to bring people
together
the last four years have seen this
country torn apart we've been divided
with fear
and hatred joe biden's not afraid to
reach across the aisle
he knows how to bring people together he
compromise
isn't a dirty word there are a lot of
things that need to get done in this
country
and i think joe biden's the man to get
him done but i want to ask about your
notion of where things the country
should be going after four years of
donald trump
um biden promised in a thanksgiving
speech life
is going to return to normal but that
doesn't sound like much of an ambition
does it
um i don't know whether you saw robert
reich the former labor secretary pointed
out that normal would be a disaster
and that's because normal led to trump
normal is four decades of stagnant wages
and widening inequality
normal is 40 years of shredded safety
nets he said and the most expensive
least adequate healthcare system in the
world normal is worsening police
brutality
why on earth does your leadership want
to go back to normal
you know i think it depends upon what
you're taking the word normal to me
i mean we've had nothing but drama
nothing but being torn apart for four
years and the ability to get nothing
done
uh unless you're a billionaire i think
that when joe biden says normal we're
going to have a national strategy plan
for attacking covet
and nothing is going to be okay until we
are doing something about covington
stopping its spread
helping those that have been impacted
helping our small businesses
uh the restaurants the people that have
been unemployed
helping with more testing and tracing
and getting the vaccine out there
that's the first step of normalcy
you know we need i'm one of the authors
of medicare for all it's one of the
things that
means the most to me it's most important
public policy for me to pursue
i will be a pain in the bazooka quite
frankly to
joe biden on the subject but i believe
we will
take steps i believe my father-in-law
was the author of social security in
this country
and my husband was one of the chief my
father-in-law and my husband were chief
architects of
medicare i think that the time comes for
those kinds of changes when you've come
out of very difficult moments like we
are
out of covet i think the time now is for
us to talk about those issues i think
people understand what when we talk
about i want to bring jobs back here
i want to make national security one of
the critical components of any
procurement
strategy when but people didn't
understand what a supply chain was
until suddenly we're in the midst of
cobit and we saw what was happening with
ppe equipment
and how dependent we were on other
countries and
that we didn't have quality goods to
make available to our nurses and doctors
but debbie did how do you deal how do
you deal with the fact that there's so
little trust in government
um for years public trust in the federal
government has hovered at near record
lows hasn't it
trust in congress is very low um just
just 20 of us adults say they trust the
government
to do the right thing always or even
most of the time just 20
arguably america is angrier and more
divided than ever isn't it
that we're coming out of the trump
administration no question and by the
way it's not just government
the i mean you see it in your own
countries uh
you see it throughout europe people are
mad at institutions they don't trust
institutions we have to rebuild the
foundations and we have to rebuild that
trust and it doesn't come
overnight but since the divisions in
your own party are staring people in the
face again
how can you be in any way qualified to
deal with those divisions
in the country at large well
i i i don't stop working at it and i
think i've got a pretty good
uh record of finding that common ground
between
people uh and the squad
and uh more moderate squad you mean the
left wing of the party
the well the squad is aoc and rashida
talib and
they're friends alexandria ocasio-cortez
yeah yeah
yes but what we must do
is have labor at the table the
progressives have to build a table
that's large enough to have everybody at
it i'm very committed to doing that and
quite frankly
already doing it but half the country
debbie dingle simply doesn't believe
the same truths that you do trump's
supporters believe
overwhelmingly that your party stole the
election
it's not a fact it's an article of faith
isn't it which
makes you in uncharted waters now joe
biden talks about
finding that sweet spot where democrats
and republicans can negotiate to
together and i'm wondering where exactly
that sweet
spot would be with such people you have
a staggering 220
out of 249 republicans in congress
that have failed to give either a clear
answer or any answer at all about who
won the presidential election
how do you find a sweet spot with people
like that
well first of all i know many of those
people and i know
i wish that they would have the courage
to speak up a little more
uh but they do know many of those people
know that donald trump has lost the
election
one of the things that i'm the angriest
about
right now is this extended period
uh by rudy giuliani and the president
uh is not resulting in anybody showing
that the election was rigged
or not handled in a very ethical manner
but it is undermining people's
confidence in the election outcome
and in the integrity we have to rebuild
it look i didn't say this was going to
be easy
but i'm not going to be as negative as
you are i am not a i'm not naive
but you don't start to fix something by
thinking it's not fixable
i believe it's fixable and i'm going to
work to do that when when you talk about
truth and the truth deficit in american
politics
it's pretty difficult for joe biden to
claim the moral high ground there
isn't it the fact-checking group
politifact compiled a scorecard of some
of his statements this year
and the results why although no means
comparable to
donald trump were somewhat less than
stellar weren't they does
that matter to you well i i don't know
that they were someone less than stellar
obviously i care if somebody tells the
truth and i want somebody to tell the
truth
you want me to tell you what really
bothers me is social media
which was founded in both years of my
lifetime to help bring people together
and it's dividing us further because we
don't have accountability
i think you're seeing countries across
the world try to figure out
how do we hold social media accountable
so it does stop spreading some of these
mistruths
these lies and is actually factually
accurate as it impacts how people think
well when joe biden
according to politifact has 19 examples
of false statements that he'd made
during the campaign this year
and a number of other statements were
labeled half true
or mostly false that's not a proud
record is it
if if the only choice in america is
between politicians
who lie a little and those who lie a lot
it's not surprising that the public
doesn't trust any of you
is it
i haven't seen this report no it's not
surprising
uh but we have to live up we have to
tell people the truth if you know me if
you know my record
i'm known for saying it as it is it
doesn't make you popular
every single day but i will tell people
exactly what i think and i think
and what i believe and what the truth is
whether they like it or not
and that's what we've got to do as
elected officials to rebuild
confidence in government so you've got
to get rid of the lies and the liars
haven't you
well i'm not quite prepared to call joe
biden the liar the way you
are i need to go look at this report but
i do know donald trump has told a lot of
lies and a lot of them have been in the
last month
you've just had america's most expensive
election
ever i've seen one estimate a whacking
14 billion dollars taking in both white
house and
congressional races you support campaign
finance report you co-sponsored last
year's for the people act that would
have
introduced some reforms to the system it
cleared the house of representatives but
you must have known
it would die on its way to the senate so
was this anything
more than just a symbolic gesture well
first of all you don't get anything done
if you don't start and if you don't try
uh and we are going to try again and if
you want to get something done
the fact of the matter is some things
take more time than any of us want to
see
we will be
you've got to build the coalition so if
you have a piece of legislation that
you've passed
and you're talking about it in states
with republican senators
but you create the demand by the people
that elected them
to do something you can eventually
get something done but your aim is to
get
money out of american politics i think
this is what you
said i hate it that's just not going to
happen though
is it because the fact is that too many
politicians from
from both sides of the aisle benefit
from loopholes
that they don't want to see closed well
i
and your party is just as bad as the
republicans in that isn't it i want to
tell you something
i think that there's nothing worse than
fundraising
i hate it i despise it everybody tells
me i can do so much more
i have no desire to be the highest
fundraiser i do what i have to do to get
re-elected i think there are a lot of
people that feel like me
i wish we could have a public option so
that everybody had the same amount of
money and had to run on the record and
who they are and what their positions
are you know if i was as negative as you
are
every single day of the week i get
nothing done but if you want to see
change you start by fighting for it i
work with many groups who are trying on
the ground
to bring about that change and i think
we will get it changed at some point
more than the literally dozens scores
hundreds of occasions on which people
have
have come into power saying we're going
to reform
campaign finance we're going to reform
the political action committees
um it's been said by so many of your
politicians over the years 20 30
40 years i remember hearing about this
it never happens do you seriously think
you can get the money what was it tip
o'neill the former speaker
who said money is the mother's milk
of american politics it was then it
still is isn't it
you know i i could go through things in
life that people said that would never
change
that they are changing i mean it it
you have to stay at it you have to be
willing
to bring about change women weren't
allowed to vote
it took hundreds of years a hundred
years of women voting to bring
about that change now we've been allowed
to vote for 100 years
blacks weren't allowed to vote it wasn't
right you know change doesn't
it makes me angry i'd like to change a
lot of things overnight
but if i had your attitude nothing's
ever going to change nothing would
change that's not the way i approach
life
i approach like these things need to
change and this is how we're going to go
try to get it to happen
let's look if we made debbie dingle at
some of biden's
early choices for senior jobs in his
administration
there seems to be some concern that in
foreign policy at least
there may be too many old faces from the
obama years coming back like john kerry
for instance
who's going to be the administration's
point man on climate change
his mantra like biden just be normal
steady unflashy decent
but that didn't work so well last time
around in foreign policy did it
well it depends who you're talking to i
quite frankly think that our foreign
policy has been a disaster we've
nobody and when you go when you talk to
other countries we haven't had normal
diplomatic relationships
in almost four years and steady
calm dependable uh foreign policy
diplomatic relations is something we
need we need to rebuild the respect
the trust and the confidence that other
countries can have in us and i think
it's just
fine but it didn't work so well with the
obama
biden administration did it um i didn't
agree with them on some things but it
did work on a number of
many other things so i mean they were
caught napping when the russians seized
crimea in 2014 the kremlin then told the
u.s to get out of the way in the eastern
mediterranean
the kids of the arab spring were thrown
under the bus when obama backed egypt's
military leaders
who regularly tortured their opponents
if all that's normal
then you really don't want to go back to
that do you i
don't want to go back to that and i'm
someone who's very active in mid-east
issues and
uh will be paying a great deal of
attention but i certainly hope you don't
think that things have been normal
under donald trump as we've withdrawn
from the world health organizations
we've drawn
withdrawn from the paris peace accord
when you look at what
our relationship is with china and
russia
a president that would meet uh and not
tell us what he discussed with
uh with putin uh that's not normal so
sorry
i i i am ready for what you might call
dull
i call steady and calm one of one of the
big issues in foreign policy always
is israel and despite being jerusalem's
closest ally the
obama biden team last time around failed
spectacularly to advance the peace
process
stop the growth of settlements or end
the occupation
you wouldn't want to repeat any of that
would you
um incidentally your party's election
platform conspicuously failed to mention
that occupation didn't it
was that despite pressure from
progressive voices
is a two-state solution it was once very
much on the table
and working forward many things uh have
made that
more pragmatic we need to deal with the
human rights violations in palestine
there are a lot of issues that need to
be
dealt with i want peace in the mid east
i'm going to be someone who is going to
push this administration to deal with it
very significantly one of the first
things that we have a commitment for is
to repeal the muslim travel ban
as just an aside as well so
you know i i think there's a lot of hope
uh for the way that some things may be
and may be handled and this is an area
especially in the mideast i will be
paying a great deal of attention to
the iranian situation is another
situation of great concern only the
u.s has the power to change policy in
israel
if you're serious about doing that and
helping palestinians to get a viable
state
then you're going to have to use a lot
more of that power than you've ever done
in the past aren't you
that's the fact of it is is tough enough
to do that
yes yes you talked about
the allies the biden team has indicated
it would like to
rebuild relations with america's allies
after the turmoil of the trump years the
rudeness
the unpredictability the orders and
threats do you think you can
paper over the diplomatic damage done by
trump
no we're not going to be a paper over
we're going to have to restore our
integrity
we're gonna have to restore people's
confidence up in us
we are going to have to act so that we
re
build and regain their trust
but the outlaws it's not something you
do the way that we've handled a number
of diplomatic relationships over the
four years
you acknowledged there were grave
mistakes made and you tried to build
back
but those allies have learned an
uncomfortable lesson from the trump
years haven't they as angela merkel said
in 2017
there were good reasons to continue
fighting for the transatlantic
relationship
but she said we can't count on it
anymore
the fact is the europeans can't be sure
that trump or someone like him
won't be coming back in four years time
and frankly you can't be sure of that
either can you
well i'm going to do everything i can to
make sure that it doesn't happen in the
congress republicans and democrats need
to find a way to send a message
to europe that they can count on us
as things stand debbie dingle trump is
leaving you to pick up the pieces from a
pandemic that he
failed disastrously to control thousands
more may die
before the vaccine gets to work one in
three adults say their
families are hungry one in four small
businesses can't stay
open a united party would struggle to
get any kind of handle on this situation
a divided one like yours will struggle
even more won't it
look nobody thinks of me as this i'm
known as debbie downer
okay let's just uh because i say it as
it is
i don't try to be down cove it's a very
serious problem and we have failed to
have a leader that's done
lead or had any kind of national plan
but i think that people are tired and
fatigued
and they're dying and they're scared and
they're ready to have a leader
lead you're going to see joe biden come
in
put together a national plan put people
in charge
it's not going to happen overnight all
of us around the world
are going to have a very difficult
winter
that if we listen to the scientists we
listen to the experts
we know that masks save lives
then hopefully with a vaccine which we
need to make sure
is available globally to everybody
then this is going to get under control
and i i
i don't think the party quit i don't
know how mass
became so uh political
or so debatable they're certainly not in
other countries
uh but i think joe biden will inspire
people to wear their masks for the first
100 days we'll see numbers go down
vaccines will become available
we have to build people's confidence up
in vaccines
and i'm hoping next christmas life's
going to be more normal for many people
if you look at the difficulty now of
agreeing a stimulus package with the
republicans in congress you can't expect
much help from them can you
even in this process i mean donald trump
hasn't
exactly shown much empathy for the
suffering and the bereavement that's
taken place
in such large numbers across america i
think with the right leader
you will you will get enough votes to be
able to do what we have to do
i think you've even seen senator
mcconnell recognize that people in
kentucky
are you can't be home you can't be in
any of your states
with the people that you represent and
not understand how scared people are how
much help they need
but they're playing politics aren't they
they they will want you to fail so they
can come back in four years time and say
hey look what a lousy job the democrats
did
you know i'm not a cynic like you are i
i actually think that the people that
wanna
they get elected on both parties because
they want to help the people they
represent
so there may be a few that are oh we
can't let them win but i think that
there are a lot of people that are
seeing the human suffering
in their districts and want to do
something to help the people they
represent
debbie dingle let's hope you're right
thanks very much for being on conflict
zone thank you
thank you
[Music]
you